Minnesota senator Amy Klobuchar is
running for the 2020 Democratic
presidential nomination she is also a
member of the Senate Judiciary Committee
and she is in Washington for an
interview you'll see only on CBS this
morning senator good morning great to
have you on thanks bianna so robert
muller couldn't prove collusion he
wouldn't decide on obstruction does this
take impeachment off the table that is
something for the House of
Representatives to determine but they
cannot make that decision piano until we
have the entire report 420 members of
the House voted that that report should
be public and that hasn't happened this
is simply a four-page letter from the
president's attorney general that
summarizes what happens and leaves open
a lot of questions like saying I'm just
looking at this now this letter that the
report sets out evidence on both sides
of the question also that quote it does
not exonerate him meaning the president
so to me if I am in the house and
looking at that question I want to see
the whole report and certainly the
public wants to see the report nearly
90% of the public have said that they
want to see the report but so there
isn't this a delicate dance for
Democrats going forward you are running
for office and you've been out there on
the stump for about a month and now how
often do voters ask you about the Russia
investigation as opposed to other issues
that's a great question and people have
so many local issues they care about the
flooding that's going on right now in
the Midwest in New Hampshire they're
worried that they're going to take a
naval yard away from them because it's
on the list of things that will help pay
for the wall but in all of that there is
always a question about democracy about
the balance of power because Americans
understand how important the
Constitution is to guard our individual
freedoms and so yes they do ask but I
think the point here is that they want
to see what happened and the most
important reason they asked it is
because they want to have an election
free of an invasion by a foreign power
and that shouldn't be forgotten here
what this four-page letter does among
many things is it makes clear that that
happened it
in two ways hacking into our election
systems as well as putting out
misinformation and I certainly want to
see all of that information into the
underlying Muller report because it
dictates what we should do going forward
I think we should have backup paper
ballots in every state in this country
there could well be another invasion and
hacking into our equipment Americans
don't want to see that
senator quickly you are a former
prosecutor and you oversee the Attorney
General as a member of the Judiciary
Committee what do you make of the
Attorney General's ruling that you can't
have obstruction if there's not an
underlying crime of collusion John I
just I don't see it quite that way but
again without seeing the facts without
seeing the entire report it is very hard
to assess any of this and bar during the
nominee during his hearing and now his
attorney general has pledged that he
wants to make everything he can public
and we're going to call him on that so
senator freeze what would it take for
Democrats to move on I don't I think our
goal here oversight is to get the facts
out for the American people please
remember in 2018 the election was about
Republicans not kicking people off of
their health insurance for pre-existing
condition 2020 is going to be very
focused on economic issues so guess what
we can do two things at once
ensure the law is followed and make sure
we're focusing on an optimistic economic
agenda for this country okay to be
continued for sure thank you very much
senator thank you sure thank you thank
you